aymeric caron bonsoir bienvenue à 4,60 à
cette heure tardive merci d'être avec
nous aymeric caron la revanche de la
nature c'est vraiment la sommation que
la nature nous donne nous à l'humanité
pour réagir à cette pandémie
oui l'idée se dit c'est effectivement de
dire attention parce que on parle
beaucoup avec les économiques et
sanitaires évidemment mais on se trouve
que on a vite oublié de s'intéresser aux
causes de la crise qui nous touche
et effectivement je voulais c'est ce que
fait que cette crise que l'on vit tous
dans le monde entier c'est une crise qui
est d'abord une crise écologique et il
faut revenir pour s'en convaincre déjà à
l'origine de ce virus ce virus a pu
émerger a pu se répandre à cause de la
manière dont on traite la nature qu'on
sait que la déforestation favorise la
diffusion des virus la manière dont on
traite les animaux également il n'y
avait pas eu de ce marché même si on est
un tueur à 100% de l'origine de ce virus
tous les scientifiques sérieux quand
même nous disent que ça vient d'eux des
animaux d'un date un marché aux animaux
donc si on n'avait pas vu ce marché avec
cette manière très particulière de
traiter les animaux
mais cela je n'aurais pas pu comme ça
passe est passé à l'homme donc ça c'est
la première leçon importante c'est
attention même si on savait déjà depuis
un an parce que quand nos politiques
hollande est étonné de deux ans et demi
avant notre départ en réali là encore
tous les scientifiques sérieux nous
disent depuis disque attend que les pans
des listes ont un des dangers majeurs
dont qui guettent l'humanité pour eux le
siècle à venir
et d'ailleurs vous prenez à témoins bill
gates vous citez bing est cependant soin
d'eux des convenait pas il est naturel
2008 déjà depuis des années prédisait
que cette pandémie frais des millions de
morts donc dans cet ouvrage
peut-être est-ce qu'on peut dire
pessimiste vous êtes quand même on
travaille trop sur les conséquences
actuellement ce qui nous arrive
actuellement et on oublie de travailler
sur les causes
ce qui risque d'arriver c'est que le
monde d'après dont on rêve risque peu de
se réaliser dans certains rêves dont
vous rêvez dont on a pu observer pendant
la pandémie pendant cette longue pause
les certains bénéfices en tout cas oui
c'est un petit peu le paradoxe de ce qui
nous arrive fois c'est décidé évidemment
un malheureux mondial avec le nombre
très important de victimes du virus
lui-même et puis elle maintenant toutes
les victimes qui arrivent ou qui ont
déjà commencé à arriver victimes de la
crise économique de pertes d'emplois et
qui essaient situation va générer encore
beaucoup de problèmes mais c'est vrai
que paradoxalement on a aussi appris
pendant ce confinement à nous souvenir
de total ou quand on produit moins parce
que évidemment l'économie a été à
l'arrêt quand on n'utilise - des
transports qui sont la voiture l'avion
puisque l'aviation étaient arrêtés
parfois 90% la voiture aussi a été très
très fortement diminué mais jo on se
rend compte que c'est bien on respire
beaucoup mieux on se rend compte que on
rentre même dans les clous de l'accord
de paris qui avait dessiné en 2015 et
qui établit des objectifs à tenir pour
que la température soit la planète
n'augmente pas de plus de 2 degrés par
rapport à l'ère industrielle
on sait très bien qu'on est absolument
pas aujourd'hui capable de respecter cet
objectif mais il se trouve que pendant
le confinement ou en france par exemple
tout à coup ça y est on réussisse à
diminuer nos émissions de co2 de manière
à rentrer dans l'accord de paris
il ya d'autres choses aussi d'autres
leçons nageurs te dire tu as cool
télétravail il faut pas arriver une
citation on serait tous ses doigts
tradition de traducteurs se serait
humainement très désagréable en revanche
on constate que une partie du travail
qui seraient effectués depuis chez soi
permettrait à notamment d'alléger
secteur des transports mais aussi de
perdre moins de temps dans sept ans au
maïdo d'avoir plus de temps pour sa
famille il ya des gens qui m'avaient dû
arrêter un peu leurs activités ont
peut-être plus se concentrer à nouveau
un petit peu sur leurs familles ou spot
des activités de loisirs mais elle était
limitée par les conséquences du
confinement
enfin en tout cas on a eu pendant cette
période où on a aussi pu beaucoup
réfléchir réfléchir à ce qu'est la vie
l'existence ce qu'est le vivre ensemble
je trouve qu'on a eu l'occasion ou
d'imaginer le montage en envoyant déjà
certains aspects on aurait pu en tirer
des échantillons ok on va se servir de
ce qu'on vient de vivre malgré nous
wathier d'imaginer le monde d'après or
on constate que toutes les décisions qui
ont été prises en sortie de confinement
sont des décisions
al'inverse exactement de ce qu'on
devrait faire priorité absolue à
l'emploi l'économie à la consommation
chez nous on parle que d'autres
consommation de reprise de la
consommation reprise de la croissance
mais aide au secteur aéronautique
ed la voiture donc alors qu'est ce que
vous proposez comme solution pour venir
en aide à ces populations ces
travailleurs à ces sonneurs à ces gens
vulnérables qui elle qui se retrouve
très souvent même à la rue dans nos
sociétés parce qu'elles n'ont plus rien
à manger dans plus de toit sur la tête
c'est un drame humain absolue pour
énormément pour des millions et des
dizaines et des 102 millions d'humains
on met évidemment qu'il faut à les aider
évidemment qu'il faut les prendre en
charge qu'il faut donner des mécanismes
de solidarité c'est une évidence absolue
ce que je dis simplement c'est que c'est
une erreur politique majeure peut
continuer à ne voir qu'un traître est
pour taire et relance des économies dont
on sait qu'elles sont polluants dont on
sait qu'elles sont nocives pour l'avenir
de l'humanité
parler du secteur aéronautique exemple
on a été très fortement ce secteur chez
nous en france avec très peu de
contreparties liées à l'environnement
l'automobile au secteur automobile aussi
qui est des gens très impacté là aussi
des êtres très important en revanche
rien ou quasiment rien pour le
développement des des transports
par exemple il faudrait dès aujourd hui
là l'erreur et mentale de tous les
gouvernements occidentaux comprendre ce
que des philosophes nous expliquer des
économistes sérieux nous explique depuis
déjà des décennies que le système
capitaliste ne peut pas perdurer
indéfiniment
c'est comme ça ça avait déjà analysé ya
au moins ce n'est pas ce que la
croissance infinie n'existe pas donc on
devrait déjà commencer aujourd'hui à
penser au système de demain c'est à dire
un système où notre manière de
fonctionner de repose plus sur la
consommation a bien mais qui d'autre
manière
alors je me posais une dernière question
parce que votre livre ce sont 27 leçon a
donc attiré le dernier jour de on vous
prenez le clavier ou la plume c'est le
jour 55 série dimanche le le 10 mai on
est aux 193 sixième jour la situation
était presque encore une fois dramatique
en france il ya une remontée une
deuxième vague ici aussi
qu'est ce que vous espériez maintenant
si vous aviez à écrire un autre chapitre
d'autant que vous avez écrit utopia il
ya quelques années vous dit que l'utopie
c'est pour s'évader mais c'est pour
affronter la réalité
en terminant je dirais que j'ai pour
l'efs dans la conduite et de ce que je
vous disais l'instance je dirais que on
attirait absolument aucune des leçons de
ce que nous venons de vivre que nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans le déni absolu
de ce qui est en train nous arriver et
bien évidemment on parle aujourd'hui des
dégâts économiques très comptait sur des
prises et des centaines de millions de
personnes
mais il faut absolument pallier ce
problème mais ça n'est pas en relançant
des économies polluantes destructrice
d'humanité dépit de lien social que nous
allons nous sauver sur le long terme
parce que aujourd'hui on va au devant de
documentation gravissime dans les dix
quinze ou vingt années à venir à cause
une crise écologique majeure et je
dirais qu'aujourd'hui l'aspect
dramatique sur quoi que en ce qui
concerne la gestion de la pandémie nos
politiques chez nous oui je vais
terminer là sud ont toujours pas pris la
mesure exacte qui est en train de se
passer avec beaucoup d'amateurisme et
d'harmonisation avec la confiance de
tous
population et notre gouvernement et
d'autres pas je disais à l'instant il
n'y a absolument aucune mesure qui est
prise aujourd'hui qui est à la hauteur
du défi écologique qui est qu il entre
alors dans ce drame quand même on va ça
c'est là-dessus aymeric caron dans la
relance de la nature à plusieurs moments
dans ce livre vous parlez de votre fille
de 2 ans et de l'émerveillement qu'elle
vous a quelle a suscité chez vous devant
ma lorsqu'elle apprend le langage
l'écriture comme respirer l'air frais
avec elle et qu'elle découvre les
oiseaux qui chantent etc etc
au fil de ces pages on voit qu'il ya
quand même un émerveillement et que
c'est votre petite fille de 22 mois à
qui vous le qui voulait susciter de tous
les autres espaces où l'émerveillement
que je décris dans ce livre des
merveilles longue touche depuis très
longtemps et que je décris toi ils
commettent clamé comme antispécistes
également céder leurs éléments de la vie
tout simplement cette icône en train de
détruire et doute vie qui s'épanouit et
admirable leurs gardes alors c'est là
dessus qu'on va célébrer car en merci
beaucoup la revente de la nature j'aime
chez albin michel au plaisir